hi i'm steve pellick the president and
chief scientific officer of connexus
bioinformatics corporation
thank you for tuning in to my
presentation
and i also like to thank the organizers
for allowing me the opportunity to tell
you a little bit what's going on here at
connexus bioinformatics corporation
specifically with respect to our our
bioinformatics programs
this topic of the conversation today is
about the oncoproteum and its study
and
if we look at cancer research today
in terms of the prevalence of the
disease this is data from the american
association for cancer research
we see the most common forms of cancer
of the breast and the profit prop the
breast and the prostate
and
other tumors uh also occur they're solid
tumors
and then the leukemias are not quite as
common but obviously deuces
represent a significant portion if we
look at the percentage
with respect to risks
we find that one in six men will get
prostate cancer and about one in eight
females will get breast cancer
the other types of cancer
occur
less frequently but in general
if you're a male your chances of getting
cancer is about one in two and as a
female one in three
now if we look at at the life expectancy
uh
with these different forms of cancer
what we see is that
over the last 50 years
in terms of cancer at all sites there's
only been
a marginal improvement of about 15
percent
above what we saw in the survival rates
from about 50 years ago fifteen to
twenty percent
and
the greatest success has been in things
like breast cancer and prostate cancer
and these reflect early diagnosis but in
the case of um the more uh other solid
type tumors
if we look at the pancreatic cancers
lung cancers
ovarian cancer really
despite the fact that there's been this
war on cancer
during this period of time
after more than 50 years of intense
research funding the nih was set up
under the johnson administration about
50 years ago in the early 60s
really the survival rates have only
increased by about 20 percent and this
is problematic because the incidence of
cancer is actually increased and so
still today about a third of all
patients
diagnosed with cancer die within five
years
when we look to see where the success
has been obviously things like prostate
cancer and
breast cancer and some forms of
leukemias and lymphomas
this is where a lot of the research
funding has been largely because of
lymphomas and leukemias are easy to
study as
single cell type cancers
with respect to the others it's really
early diagnosis it's helped a lot
now the problem is that
despite the fact that we've sequenced
the genome about 10
years ago
we still don't actually know what about
40 percent of the genes do and it's an
estimated uh
something between 21 to 22 000
genes that are coding for proteins in
the human genome
and of these about 3000 are linked to
the development of cancer
one way or the other
so
the real problem is that every single
human tumor that's primary
may in fact be unique
in its etiology
and every uh tumor may be heterogeneous
within its population of cells
in the types of mutations that it
features
so the complexity of the human genome
and the proteome is a major
a major problem
with respect to a barrier for improving
diagnosis and treatments of cancer
simply because the complexity of the
disease
now my presentation is going to address
a few different features i'm going to
summarize the efforts of connexxus to
create an open access bioinformatics
database
with websites for the study of cell
signaling systems both under normal and
neoplastic conditions and the
opportunity here is that this can help
facilitate research
in this field
i'm also going to summarize
some of the results of queries of these
databases
with respect to both gene mutation
and
diverse human cancers
i'm going to introduce the concept of
tumor-requiring proteins we've heard of
oncogenes and we've heard of tumor
suppressor genes and i think there's a
third category of genes that's actually
even more interesting for their
potential for therapeutic
development
and finally i'm going to especially
focus on protein kinases as diagnostic
markers
and therapeutic drug targets
so if we look at
today a lot of interest is in the
methylation of genes and
with respect to epigenomic studies and
of course the methylation genes can turn
them off
but if they're activated
we get the production of mrnas and these
in turn can be regulated by the
production of about a thousand different
mrnas encoded by the human genome
and of course these facilitate the
degradation of the mrnas before they're
translated into proteins
if they are successfully translated into
proteins
most these proteins may in fact be
inactive
they can be rapidly degraded by
proteases
but to be fully active most proteins
undergo covalent modification more than
a thousand type sorry hundred types of
covalent modification are known
and
the primary the premier
form of modification is protein
phosphorylation catalyzed by protein
kinases
and about three times as often as uh
inactivation
is activation of proteins by their
phosphorylation where functional
information is known
and so when we look at a phenotype like
cancer it's really reflection of the
amount of active protein that's
available that gives rise to the
phenotype
and
these proteins
serve really as the main targets for
drug development
protein kinases uh currently represent
about a third of all r d activity in the
pharmaceutical industry
so this is really where the a lot of
focus that connexus has been over the
last 15 years
so again the human proteome has about 21
500 proteins roughly
and
out of that a portion called the kino is
a
contains about
536 to 538 protein kinase genes and
these undergo alternative splicing which
can give rise
to
other isoforms
these kinases catalyze the
phosphorylation of the almost most of
the proteins encoded by the human genome
in fact
and
over 200 000 of phosphorylation sites
have been demonstrated
experimentally by mass spectrometry
at connexus we've used advanced
algorithms uh with training from these
200 000 phosphorylation sites to predict
another 1 million a
total of about a million human
phosphorylation sites additional 800 000
roughly
and this number is in fact quite quite
realistic uh we know about four percent
of the phosphorylation sites identified
by mass spectrometry in random studies
where there isn't enrichment for
phosphotyrosine
uh there's about forty thousand sites
uh they're known and four percent of the
sites so you can kind of back calculate
that in fact that does support a number
close to a million human phosphorylation
sites if one in 25
are on tyrosine there's 40 000 of these
sites then 40 000 times 25 gives you
close to a
million now these sites are are
dephosphorylated by a
phosphaton uh which
consists of at least 156 genes of code
protein phosphatases for the reversible
reaction
now we've created
the fossil net website a few years ago
and just recently updated it and we'll
be updating it again shortly
access to this site is uh through
dot www.foxnet.ca as you can see in the
upper corner
if you go to the main connexxus website
and scroll to the bottom of the main
site
and that's at
www.connexus.ca we're based in canada
then you can find access to all the
websites that i'm talking about today
that are currently online
um i think what i like to do is take you
directly to the fossil net website
and
i'll do that momentarily
so hopefully you can see on the screen
of live feed
from the connexus website and it's a
very user friendly website
all you do is enter the name of a
protein of interest
in this case i'll type in erc1
protein kinase when you type the first
three characters it gives you a list of
options
and as you go to the site
what you see
is a little bit of information about the
protein at first
and
then at the bottom
is a listing of the phosphorylation
sites that are known and predicted in
this case we have about 37 sites that
are
predicted or known for the irk1 protein
kinase
you'll notice that there is a bunch of
buttons under the experiment
confirmed column exp co and f
and this um
this column has white and and green
buttons the white buttons correspond to
sites that have been experimentally
validated and if you click on that
button
it actually
puts the information that's associated
with that with the link
in the information box so you can copy
and paste it
but if you take the
um
your cursor and you go over and above
the
buttons then the information appears in
the box right next to the data so for
example
the tyrosine 204 site in this tey
sequence
is known to be an activating site and so
under the functional column it tells you
increases activity
and it tells you when you scroll to the
next column that's phosphorylated by lck
irc 1 jack 2 and of course mech 1 and
mech2 which are the is well known to
phosphorylate this site
and it's d phosphorus
by uh map kinase phosphatase ii
now to the right of these is another set
of three columns of buttons the first
gives you a direct link to the public
med website with information on that
and then the next set of buttons gives
you information on the evolutionary
conservation of that site so if we go to
that click that button
you'll see fossil net evolution appear
and fossil net evolution will list for
20 different species the location of
that phosphorylation site
and
the actual number and uniprot or ncbi
reference numbers for that site and if
you scroll down a little
further
for the different species it tells you
the percent amino acid identity or
similarity calculated for the whole
cognitive protein in the different
species relative to the human protein
and
the 15 amino acids surrounding the
phosphorylation site itself for identity
and similarity
another useful feature
of this website
is
um
let me just go back
to my previous site sorry
let's see
here we go is the
last set of buttons now this is the
kinase predictor website
and for this website if we click on it
we developed an algorithm trained with
about 22 000 kinase substrate pairs with
the phosphorylation sites
and using information the primary
sequence of protein kinases
we then
developed the algorithm with the
training
to take and develop a matrix for the 500
of the human protein kinases
and then for the 1 million human
phosphorylation sites what we did was we
we
tested and scored each of those
phosphorylation sites against each of
these kinases and the top 50 kinases are
listed
and the highest score that's possible is
a thousand
and what you see here is that our
algorithm predicts mequon and mc2 is the
most likely kinases that phosphorylate
that site we also developed a second
analysis that takes into account
neighboring phosphorylation sites that
might improve the prospect
that particular phosphorylation site
would be phosphorylated
by those kinases so it's a second way of
improving the
prediction of the protein kinases
okay so if we go back now to the slide
presentations i'm going to
go
now and discuss more about
cancer itself and come back historically
for its role in oncology
obviously protein kinases were
identified early in cancer research as
playing a critical role
and of course the first oncogene
discovered indirectly by peyton roose
more than 100 years ago
in the rauster coma virus uh is a gene
that encodes a protein kinase
and he of course received the nobel
prize for that uh later in the 60s
now the gene
that
was in the rel sarcoma virus that was
transduced is the sarc gene for sarcoma
contains three well well-known domains
this sh-1 domain is the protein kinase
domain the sh2
and sh3 domains involved in protein
interactions the sh3 domains recognize
phosphotyrosine
and sh3 domains recognize regions with
rich and
proline polyproline sequences
and of course a lot of excitement
happened
when these genes were first sequenced
um by mike bishop and harold varmus
and they determined that uh
this was in fact a protein kinase
because the sh1 domain was clearly
recognized as having homology with
cyclic amp-dependent protein kinase and
cyclic gmp-dependent protein kinase from
studies from ed krebs's lab
what made it particularly intriguing was
that that kinase catalyzed the
phosphorylation on tyrosine residues and
this was um discovered in tony hunter's
lab um shortly thereafter
and the rest is sort of a bit history
now as it turns out
many different retroviruses transduce
normal cellular genes that may become
mutated as part of that process but
they're carried by the virus
and a lot of these genes turn out to
encode protein kinases often protein
tyrosine kinases there are of course
other proteins that are encoded
including g proteins
and
we also know that the virus integration
can be close to the site of another
normal cellular gene and often result in
its overexpression
and many of those genes that are
affected encode protein kinases
uh by the way most of these tables that
are on here they're very complex and
they're they're provided for your
reference you can download this material
directly from this website
and hopefully be useful in your research
and teaching
now many of the oncogenes are identified
in the birds and mammals
were also found in association with
human cancers as
developed by
a look and see what genes are amplified
in frequent in regions that are
frequently amplified in cancers they
were also identified by studies of
dna transfection from tumors using
robert weinberg's approach
so
as it turns out a lot of these protein
tyrosine kinases are receptor-based
tyrosine kinases is about 60 of them and
they all share this catalytic domain
about 247
or so amino acids in size and they
catalyze the phosphate and proteins and
tyrosine and
many of these uh mutations that occur in
human cancers involve uh chromosomal
rearrangements and uh formation of
of chimeric uh genes where the protein
kinase catalytic domains
of receptor tyrosine kinases are often
fused with other proteins that in fact
induce the
dimerization of those proteins so that
they may be constitutively active as
protein tyrosine kinases
normally uh when we look at these
receptors
these are receptors for growth factors
and mitogens
and these induce the dimerization and
the activation of these protein kinases
with
autophosphorylation auto in the sense
that one catalytic domain is
phosphorusing
the other chain that's in the dimeric
complex
and these set up uh sites of
phosphorylation of proteins and these
kind of translocations of genes that
induce
uh constitutive type dimerizations are
extremely common in cancers as well and
i have a list here of some of those gene
translocations
now
defining an oncogene
i think is is um
something that isn't exactly clear
the way i'm i define it as
a protein that has a gain of function
as a consequence of a mutation and most
of these mutations tend to be very
restricted
in what they do they may mimic an
activating site
as we see with the b raf protein the
valine 600 e mutation
where the glutamic acid
is mimicking the negative charge of a
phosphate
and this is in the activation loop of
the kinase as we'll see
shortly
it can also
result
often in the inactivation of an
inhibitory region on the protein as is
evident in the k-ras protein
that may be the production of a gene
that is a gene product that actually has
a gain of function it catalyzes a
reaction that it doesn't normally
catalyze in the case of isocitrate
dehydrogenase one
may also uh inhibit the degradation of
the protein so it sticks around longer
and so when we take a look at
oncoproteins
we see that they do have these very
narrow mutations and it's generally
generally tends to be point mutations
very few complex
insertions and mutations and deletions
are evident
and here if we take a look at the cosmic
database as an example is here we look
at k ras we can see in the upper
panel
the location of across the gene sequence
of the k
with the occurrence of mutations and
these are point mutations
and then below we have deletions that
are are in blue and
red insertions and other complex
mutations so you can see that the
pattern
is very restricted and so
using this kind of approach you can take
a look at
the cosmic database and other websites
that feature mutation information and
start to anticipate
whether or not
um
whether or not this is in fact um
uh potentially an oncoprotein is
something that we've looked into at
connexus and we're making available to
you
with the onconet website i'll be
describing to you shortly
again
in this case
the positioning of a glycine residue
mutated to any other amino acid
interferes with the binding of the
phosphates in gtp and the subsequent
hydrolysis
of the gtp by the gtps activity of the
ras protein and so it stays
constitutively active in the gtp bound
form
so when we look at
many of these sites in protein kinases
there's a region uh called the subdomain
seven region that contains a sequence
dfg that's highly conserved in about 492
of the human protein kinases
and we also have
the subdomain eight region which has an
ape sequence typically and intervening
between these two sequences the dfg and
the ape is what we call the activation
loop of protein kinases
and this is the location of many of the
sites that are known to be activating in
protein kinases
we have other work going on at connexus
that we'll be presenting shortly
that shows that in fact there's also an
auto inhibition sites closer to the
p e region
occurs especially in serine three
protein kinases but that's a story for
another day
so in the case of uh the
raf b protein as i mentioned earlier the
valine 600d mutation
uh occurs on the valine
is converted to a glutamic acid and this
results in a mimicking of
phosphorylation and hence the
constitutive activation of the protein
okay so the problem is that with the
sequencing of all these genomes um
there's about 60 million
snps that are anticipated to exist and
snp is defined simply as a gene
where there's a mutation at that
location in about one percent of the
human population so in fact there may be
even a lot higher number of these
polymorphisms
and
the sequencing the whole sequencing of
genomes from tumors in comparison the
data with normal tissues from patients
is uncovering shared mutations and genes
include both proteins and microrna has
been a great deal of interest in
identifying these and
that we put a lot of effort towards this
at connexus as well
there seems to be about 2500 genes that
are abnormally mutated in very diverse
types of cancer
and the cosmic database from the sanger
institute
basically with this link is a great
place to
look and peruse the gene of interest
that you may have
about what mutations it may feature
in a wide range of different human
cancers
now with snip chips
these microarrays allow the
identification in patient samples of
important snps and that's largely how a
lot of the companies that are currently
offering services for gene profiling or
working is with these chips to ascertain
what uh people's risks are for different
types of cancer and other diseases i
think this is actually quite premature
as i'll explain further in the
presentation
and pretty soon
the whole idea of using sip chips will
be supplanted really by genome-wide
sequencing as the costs come down and
there are plans to sequence over a
hundred thousand genomes
um in the uk and other um countries
in cancer to try to identify oncogenes
personally i think we have enough
information to already start to identify
key players in these
is this
this disease a really set of diseases
and
i think that's actually a wasted effort
at this point in time
already we can now identify uh and the
data here is based on sometimes as many
as a hundred thousand tumors analyzed
for mutations
what are the most frequently mutated
genes in human cancers and for those of
you who can't see it on the screen
at the top of the list is k raz and then
nnp1
jack 2 protein kinase
one the protein kinase b raf
my d88 flt3 kt
kit i should say
fgfr3 egf um are
hraz and so as you go down the list what
you becomes quite evident is the most
commonly mutated genes tend to be
encoding protein kinases and g proteins
and most human cancers
and
k-ras is is highly mutated
and
when you're talking look talking about
mutation rate because these proteins are
of different sizes
it actually is much more germane to
express them in terms of mutation rate
per 100 amino acids and so we do this we
see that in all of these different
tumors
about
11.3 percent of all of these cancers had
a mutation in the k ras protein and then
it drops off quite quite drastically
after that in terms of mutation rate so
for most the common um genes that are
related to cancer that are known
oncogenes they have less than about a
one to two percent and lower rate of
mutation per hundred amino acids
well the tumor suppressor genes they
have a quite different profile
and they're typically mutated broadly
they feature many types of mutations as
the general loss of function of these
proteins drives cancer development and
it's easy to make something not work by
mutating it so
therefore the entire protein is actually
open to mutations that might result in a
loss of function and it could inactivate
a catalytic domain it might prevent the
binding of activators to downstream
targets
it may stimulate the degradation of a
protein
and these tend to be more hereditary
type mutations that are occurring
we take a look at p53 a classical case
of a
ponca protein and it was actually
originally identified as a protein that
was increased in expression in cancer
and thought maybe
stimulate cancer in fact of course we
now know that it's the loss of function
of this protein
that is driving cancer and
the cells are trying to produce the
protein and ineffectual protein in order
to compensate for the growth signals
that are inappropriate for the growth of
the cancer
and here we can see that it's loaded
with point mutations
complex mutations insertions deletions
and so this is a more characteristic
pattern for a tumor suppressor protein
now i've we've gone and we've analyzed
in our databases uh
what are the most commonly mutated
tumor suppressor proteins with these
complex patterns and many of them as i
said are inherited
and they encode often transcription
factors and inhibitors of protein
kinases
and also sometimes protein kinases
themselves but
largely transcription factors uh it
seems to really pop up the most
and of course p53 and rb so
cyclin-dependent kinase inhibitor
cdkn2a
is actually the most commonly mutated
gene in human cancers and then p53 after
that
and
the vhl and involving protein synthesis
and p10 follow that
so this gives you an idea of some of the
genes and when we look at the mutation
rates though they do fall quite
dramatically after the first few again
so
when we consider the most common forms
of human cancer
if there may well be over
um
several hundred oncopro oncogenes and
there may be several hundred tumor
suppressor genes
and it's combinations of the loss of
function of the oncogenes and sorry the
gain of function the oncoproteins and
the loss of function of the tumor
suppressor proteins the number of
combinations can literally be
astronomical could be in the billions so
that's why it's very likely that every
person has a very unique form of cancer
although there are certainly certain
genes that are the most commonly
affected in in many cancers but from an
individual basis you have to figure out
for that person what it is
now one of the things that we've done at
connexus is to then analyze for these
mutation rates in individual types of
solid tumors and
we can start to see patterns that
certain genes the ones that are the most
commonly affected in cancer this
the cdkn2a and the p53 and the k ras and
p10 and nras these seem to be very
commonly affected in a wide range of
different types of human cancers but
then there are other types of cancers
where what we see is that there are
certain genes that are highly mutated in
association with that cancer so for
example the
tm1 gene
uh it's quite a
higher rate in cervical cancer and the
imifit
m3 gene is also very highly affected in
cervical cancer
so we observe um this is a second going
further down the list
these are all oncoproteins and tumor
suppressor proteins
and the the rates of of
different types of cancer show different
preferences for mutated genes
but some tissues like lung and
endometrial cancers
sometimes breast do show high rates of
mutation of many different types of
genes
okay so if we take a look at the 550
most commonly mutated genes in human
cancers
the ones that are defined as
oncoproteins or tumor suppressor
proteins we find that that accounts for
about half
of the genes that we see that are
mutated in cancer quite significantly
the other half were actually
unclassified
and
we can see that for the oncoprotein
group um the 78 of those at least 71 of
them clearly have a gain of function
some of them though
also known to be tumor suppressor
proteins in a different context
likewise with the tumor suppressor
proteins 140
of the 199 clearly have a loss of
function
but there's about 46 where the
functional effect is unclear and some
that even in the right context could
actually promote cancer
if we look at the distribution of these
oncoproteins and tumor suppressor
proteins in terms of the categories of
different types of
families of
genes that are affected
the transcription factors show up quite
highly about fourteen percent of the uh
most commonly mutated proteins and then
the protein kinases
uh with tyrosine and followed by the
serine threatening protein kinases
through quite high
adhesion proteins and scaffolding
proteins are another group
and these give you an idea that
certainly protein kinases do show up
prominently
well
this data that i've presented to you
it's in fact uh can be derived
from our open access onconet website we
have a beta site that's available to
look at it's www.onconnet.ca
and currently it's not officially
launched but
a beta version like i say is online
and it features information on about
3000 proteins that have been previously
linked
to cancer one way or the other and it
tries to contain information both on
gene expression patterns
and also the mutation again much of the
data was originally collected from the
cosmic database
but one of the problems from the cosmic
database is that you can approach it if
you know the protein but it's hard to
approach it from the standpoint of a
different type of particular type of
cancer so this is one of the things that
we've tried to build into our website
and we've classified the proteins as
oncoproteins tumor suppressor proteins
and this new group of proteins i'd like
to talk to you about
called
tumor requiring proteins trps
now we can go
online to the onconet website briefly
and
if we go online
basically there's a number of options in
the menu that you can click
on the queries of the types
you can pick a protein of interest a
tumor type or a protein
and let's say let's
take a protein for example
i'll do a protein listing let's do a
simple one that's well known
like
erb b2
um
just
first i'll go to the tumor type protein
listing
so now a menu appears and
basically uh you can list the type of
tumor
protein you're interested in
let's say here's a tumor suppressor type
then you can list different types of
functional types if you want to narrow
it down or you can just do the whole
list leave it unspecified
and
then you can select
from a different possible outputs that
you can vary the menu but you can just
generate a list of um
a table of the
listing of proteins now
this list appears pretty fast and it'll
list
a lot of these onco tumor tumor
suppressor proteins
okay so
um i was going to do the listing from um
let's say a
protein listing again
you
list the um
if there's a protein of interest
you can go
you have to list the type of
analyses that you want
whether it's a gene mutation analysis or
an expression analysis so we can go gene
mutation
and we can uh
select then from the cancer type that we
want or are unspecified
but let's say let's pick
something like breast cancer
and
then picked the most
top 50 most mutated and it generates the
table
and again much of this data is retrieved
from the
cosmic database and some others
here you can slide across and start to
see some of the
values now this is a beta version so we
have not yet
added our latest database that has the
information from
at least seven thousand human tumors
for each of the genes so this version uh
hasn't got all the information there
so we're about to we have the database
already created uh what's holding up all
connect being launched is that
when we have descriptions of the
proteins uh presently you can
do a protein
description you can type in the name of
the protein you're interested in like
herb v2
a little extra b there
and
retrieve the information on it
and so we have a lot of detailed
information on the protein if it's using
clinical trials sometimes if there's
information about
drugs that can be used on it
and so we're just updating this
information for many more of the genes
and then we'll be launching it
so that's the onconet website
okay back to our presentation slides
okay
okay so now
sorry let's go to the next slide
so one of the interesting things that
came out of
this analysis
to look for tumor suppressor proteins
and oncoproteins
was that we could look at the rate of
mutation per amino acids
and we found that
the vast majority of the 3 000 entries
including a lot of entries that had
nothing to do with cancer
had mutation rates that were typically
in the order of about uh
0.025
to um
to 0.5 percent
and this is where you can see the the
bulk of these mutations here so i'm
sorry that the
data doesn't appear for
on the scale for what the percent is but
there is a sub group here
that actually have mutation rates that
are far lower than the average that's
determined here both the median and the
average rate
under percent rate per hundred amino
acids in this bottom box
uh to the very left you see that there's
um
there's a median value of 0.08 percent
roughly of all human
genes have mutations in cancers
that is if you have a
a
bystander gene
there is
about point zero eight percent of the
time it will have a mutation every
hundred amino acids
it's not that much higher for many genes
that are known cancer genes
so this is one of the problems with
sequencing the genomes of a large number
of people
is that you're going to get this
background level going up
and so it may be hard to see
mutations that may in fact be
contributing to the cancer
disease
but what's really really interesting to
me is that there is a subgroup that
actually has a much lower rate
of mutation so
there's about 176 entries that have a a
rate that's less than 0.025 percent
and uh about 85 entries at a rate that
was less than 0.01 percent
so these
these genes
apparently
will not undergo mutation
now obviously they probably do undergo a
mutation but in a
growing tumor
if a population a cell acquires
mutations in these proteins it's
probably
compromises the survival of that cell
and so there's a process
where there's a natural selection
that of course is favoring the retention
of oncoproteins and tumor suppressor
protein mutations
but is also restricting any mutations on
these tumor-requiring proteins
so one of the interesting questions then
is what is the
what are these tumor uh requiring
proteins um they seem to be resistant to
mutations and we believe that they are
required for the actions of
oncoproteins so loss of their function
may compromise on the ability of
oncoproteins to signal in cells to
stimulate cell growth and other
activities that are necessary for
development of metastasis for example
so these rates of mutation at least
tenfold lower than in most cancer cells
72 of these proteins that we analyzed
and over 7000 tumors had only either
none or only two mutations sometimes
these trps are protein kinases
and so here's a list
of what we believe are these
tumor-requiring proteins that are the
least mutated in human cancers and they
often undergo changes in expression in
human cancers most typically
on up regulation in human cancers
and amongst this list
interestingly is herb b3
so this is a protein kinase a receptor
tyrosine kinase it's thought not to be
active
it forms complexes
with the egf receptor and erb2 and herb
b4
and it's thought that it in fact um
allows
uh
through cross-phosphorylation although
it's not active as a tyrosine kinase
itself
it will become phosphorus and tyrosine
residues and these set up docking sites
for sh2
and ptb containing domain containing
adapter proteins to then form signaling
complexes
i suspect that actually
it may in fact be a
important in cancer action
but not as important to some of these
other
genes because its mutation rates a
little bit higher
as a trp
okay so what we're seeing then is if we
have a receptor singling complex and the
binding of these uh adapter proteins
uh for singling these can turn on for
example from the sos activation of raz
the turning on of a cascade of protein
kinases that is serine threonine kinases
which can culminate in the activation of
transcription factors
and we can also through
a
generation of second messengers like
some of the phosphatidyl and also
phospholipids
uh generate
second messengers that activate protein
kinase c in the pdk akt type signaling
pathways when we look at these pathways
and all these integrated proteins
we look to see how many of these are
oncoproteins these are outlined in green
now
you can observe
that the
the
these all integrate into a common
signaling pathways
if we look at tumor suppressor proteins
these are also integrated into the same
pathways usually
regulating the activities
of these activated proteins for cell
growth
the
tumor requiring proteins the trps
outlined in yellow here
risk isoforms and isoforms
these serine threonine kinases act
downstream they may be required
so these oncoproteins turn out to be
quite interesting
uh potentially as both drug targets
because they are protein kinases and
also because they don't undergo
mutations so easily
they may in fact uh
not
as drug targets be as amino as
susceptible
to developmental resistance over time so
i think these represent a very important
class of potential targets for drug
development
now one of the other websites that
connexxus has developed
is the transcriptone website
now the information in the transcriptone
website
is available um in the alternet website
but right now
transcriptone is online and it's a very
useful resource to interrogate a large
number of genes not only in the context
of cancer
but also just normal gene expression and
diverse uh types of
tissues
so you can do different types of query
and
if you click on the button which is
over to view options you get a list of
potential queries that you can do
and one of the queries is the cancer
gene
expression query and so for this query
what you observe is that
you can pick a particular cancer that
you're interested let's say
glioblastomas in the brain
and then you can see what genes are the
most upregulated or the most down
regulated
and so here we can look to see the most
upregulated genes
we hit the search button
and it generates a table
all these tables are downloadable as in
ms x
ms
excel spreadsheet format
and you can peruse through
and observe
what
what the
gene expression levels appear to be
based on mrna expression data now the
creation of this website was really
based
on pulling the data from about 5000 gene
expression studies that were deposited
in the geodatabase of the ncbi
and in some cases there may be an n of
only one or two for the tissues but in
many cases what we did was we normalized
the data across all of the gene chips
using
about 60 commonly expressed proteins
that were highly expressed in all these
various tissues and then normalized the
data to those
so
while it's not perfect it's it is a very
nice place to start
and you can get quite a bit of
information
on comparing different tissues how
related they are to each other in gene
expression
you can look to see
basically from a tissue standpoint where
the most common genes where the most
uniquely expressed genes for that tissue
you can look also from a
protein standpoint or gene standpoint
where these genes most highly expressed
or
most uniquely expressed or most commonly
expressed
okay coming back again to the
slides
as i said transcriptanet basically is uh
data is pulled from
as it turns out about uh 50 000 studies
is featured in the geodatabase but we
only pull the data from the normal
tissue and human
cancer tissue so we have about 300
cancer cell lines that are covered about
250 different types of
human cancers
sorry about 50 types of human cancers in
about 250 types of different human
tissues
okay has about 21 000 genes that are
covered and this represents about 125
million measurements for gene expression
okay
so it's a it's an open access resource
and i encourage you to use it um
and as it turns out it's very useful for
something i'm going to show you shortly
our kin atlas database
now looking at all of these genes that
are up regulated in human cancers
from this database
we observe that about 12 percent of the
up regulated genes are known
oncogenes
and about 12 percent of them are tumor
suppressor genes
but in fact um
76 of these genes don't have a direct
link to cancer
if we take a look at um the most down
regulated genes 136 of those
13 of those are oncoproteins
and 10 of tumor suppressor proteins and
again 76
are not really linked to cancer
uh at this point
so this is a listing of some of the
genes that are the most commonly
upregulated in human cancers and the way
this is read is that
each little square represents a
different tissue but the tissues are
organized
by each row so they're sorted within
each each row
so that the strongest signals
for an increase is black
and then green and then yellow is where
there's almost no changes and then red
is where they actually go down so in
some tissues some of these genes where
they're highly increasing expression
in other tissues they may actually be
slightly reduced in expression
but these are the most commonly affected
genes
again we see that verb b3
is in fact the most commonly one of the
most commonly upregulated protein
kinases that we could see
in cancer and so my thinking of herbi3
is that it probably truly is a tumor
suppressor protein
and that it's upregulated to inactivate
activated receptor tyrosine kinases
and um
it probably represents an ideal target
for the development of monoclonal
antibodies in fact
such
antibodies are already in the clinical
trials and may in fact
be a very useful treatment perhaps
better than some of the
rb2 targeting
monoclonal antibodies that are presently
on the market
here's a list of the genes that are the
most down regulated human cancers
again uh dark red represents strong down
regulation
and
yellow is no change and green slight
increases
so
the idea here is that are these
biomarkers for human cancers and do they
provide us with insights into the
regulation that's going on
in human cancers
well
one of the things that i would
suggest is that
really in the previous
slide that i showed you
with respect to the distribution in
these cancers
where we see that there's an up
regulation of oncogenes
in
uh down regulation of only genes and
human cancers and up regulation of tumor
suppressor genes and human cancers i
don't think it's so easy to predict from
these patterns of gene expression which
ones are actually contributing to the
development of the cancer and which are
actually responses of the cell to try to
correct for the miscommunication from
the
um the mutations of these genes
to compensate and so really in cancer
although there's obviously a battle of
the immune system to try to fight the
growth of the cancer cell going on in an
individual with cancer there's actually
a battle going on inside the cancer cell
itself to try to compensate uh for this
uh
defective signaling
and when
that growth control was lost then you
get basically
unregulated cell growth and that
contributes to growth of cancer and then
also later
metastasis
okay so
since protein kinase show up repeatedly
as very important targets for drug
development
currently there's over 19 small molecule
drugs that are inhibitors of protein
kinases that are effectively used for
treatment of cancer there's more than
150 that are in clinical trials
probably more than 500 that are complete
clinical trials as i mentioned earlier
about a third of all r d
uh in pharmaceutical industry is
targeting protein kinases protein
kinases while most of the interest has
been from the oncology perspective
protein kinases have been linked to over
400 different diseases so
much of these inhibitors have been
developed for cancer may have much wider
applications for example and
neurological disorders
which are thought to be more affected
than uh with protein kinases than
perhaps cancer itself
so there's a great deal of promise here
and i
predict that
certainly within the next five to ten
years
i expect about half of all the r d
development will be targeting protein
kinases
based on success that's happened so far
so
one of the things that we've created
that i think is a really helpful
resource
for the scientific community
is drug kina and um i'm going drug kina
is basically a human protein kinase drug
knowledge base
it features experimental results that
we've collected from the literature from
other websites
for 400 kinases
with 850 different compounds that are
known to inhibit kinases and what we
recorded is the lowest ki ic50 or kd
value that's been reported for that
particular kinase for that particular
drug in a pair
and
we use that data much as we trained our
algorithms to recognize
phosphorylation sites for recognition by
protein kinases based on the amino acid
sequence of the kinase
we also use the training data from the
kinase drug pairs and the sequence
information on the protein kinases
to predict uh the interactions another
two hundred thousand kinase drug pairs
with 500
of the kinases
so this really allows you to take an
existing drug
and potentially identify
off-target kinases that might be
affected by that drug
and it has uh strong links
to other websites and provides
information on each of these drugs
so
in the interest of time um
i encourage you to take a look at the
drug kina website and uh and visit it
and see how it's useful to you
now the
final talk
presentation is really based on
what we're trying to do with these
websites to integrate them into
databases
and we have a number of other websites
that you can look at um if you take a
look at the powerpoint presentation as
we're running low on time
uh you'll be able to see
um information on data that was
generated at connexus uh using our
proteomics technologies
and these uh websites uh involve data
from immunoblotting and from antibody
microarrays
and with our antibody micrae
western blotting website we have about
ten thousand
uh amino blots that are quantified with
data generated for three hundred
antibodies over two hundred thousand uh
measurements and these are online
and over ninety five percent of this
data is actually unpublished but it's
open access the other database is our
kynet database for antibody microarray
and this data
is open access as well it has results
from about 2500 microarrays that we've
run with as many as 850 antibodies on
chips
and this is searchable and again 99 of
the data
is unpublished
now the last thing i want to talk about
is there's two mapping initiatives that
are currently underway at connexus one
is the connections maps these are many
maps using only experimental data that's
uh target-centric that is you have a
protein of interest usually a kinase and
we're interested in the upstream
activators and downstream regulators
and with our antibody micro analyses
we're going to be generating these maps
to to map the data from that but these
maps will be available to use for
teaching and for other purposes so
here's an example of a map for the jack
2 protein kinase again this is the
kinase it's the most commonly one of the
most commonly mutated kinases in human
cancers
so it lists the name of the protein
and the unit id number in the purple
area and then all the phosphorylation
sites
that are affected on the map
these are targeted uh green for
activatory red for inhibitory grade
where the functional effect is unclear
and so we would identify
those protein kinases that target these
sites directly
if it's known if it's unknown then it'll
be a direct connection and
autophosphorylation
we also are listing protein interactions
uh with the target protein
and at the same time we have a list of
uh
targets that are downstream of that
protein kinase
that are known to be either activated or
inhibited
so we are generating hundreds of these
maps and uh there will be open access
and available
the other though map that we're most
interested is the kin atlas database
this is the most versatile this is in
development it'll be online we hope
shortly
it identifies
uh protein protein interactions kinase
substrate interactions and kinase drug
interactions and it actually integrates
the information and provides links to
all these fossil net transcription drug
net websites as well as uniprot and
other uh websites
and the way this works is it generates
new maps for the associated protein as
the hub of the map it's in the center of
a wheel so we have an interface that
you'll be able to customize with respect
to what's being shown whether it's
predicted data
and experimental or experimental only or
only kinases or um only functionally
affected proteins so the kind of map
that you're going to see is a a link
where
the center of the map is the target and
whether the interaction is upstream or
downstream
indicated by the direction of the arrow
and the size of the icon is related to
the amount of the protein and these maps
are tissue specific or cell specific so
about 600 different types of uh queer
redeemable maps for a given protein
depending on the tissue that you're
looking at
the length of the distance is related to
how strong the phosphorylation
connection is as predicted
you also have protein protein
interaction maps largely pulled from
information from the
string database
and again the stronger the score for
experimental data the stronger
interaction
and then we have also a drug interaction
database with kinases
and what's unique about these maps is
that if you click on one of the
peripheral
components in the map it becomes the hub
of a new map
and shows you all its interacting
players so for example if you saw a drug
that's
the santa nib was strong effect on able
here you can click on this antenna and
it becomes the center of a hub and you
see all the associative proteins
so i apologize that the talk has gone
a little over
there's a lot to cover
there's a lot of people that are
responsible for allowing me to put this
data together and to create these
websites
and
i'm quite
grateful to them
i'm also thankful to the organizers for
the opportunity to present this work
and to you for taking the time of your
busy schedules to see what it is that
we're doing
i'll
take a few
questions
uh and the q a
section and if there's any questions
uh be happy to see them presently i
don't see any questions
so i guess
we can call that
the end of the session
and i
urge you to try to take a look at these
websites and to use them i think they're
very powerful
for designing experiments
and we have other websites that are in
development as well
uh one
on protein kinases another one that's a
a publication database where a lot of
the data i'm showing today will be in a
publishable format for you to refer to
so again thank you very much and uh
good luck with your own research
and goodbye
bye